so movement and motility is almost
synonymous with life when you peer
inside the inner life of a cell with a
microscope you can see that it's
churning with moving objects many of
these moving objects are small cargo
containers called membrane organelles or
vesicles these are essentially the
delivery trucks of the cell at the time
we were doing this experiment in 1984 we
really didn't have answers to those
fundamental questions of how that
motility occurs so our goal was to
figure it out
so we figured if we were going to
understand motility we should look at it
in a system which has the highest
concentration of all of these motility
components these moving organelles the
motor proteins and that's why we picked
the axon the axon is effectively a
dedicated Highway to molecular transport
a nerve cell unlike a liver cell or many
other cells is extraordinarily long one
part of the cell may be in your spinal
cord but the other end of that same cell
may be at the tip of your toe and in
between that cell body and your spinal
cord in your toe is a very very long
tube that's called the axon that
connects these very distal parts of the
same cell and this is essentially like
shipping things between one part of the
country and the other of all the axons
that you can possibly choose which one
would you choose
well we decided to work on the squid
giant axon it is a much larger axon than
an axon that you would find in a mammal
for example or a human
we made the guess that this would be a
good hunting ground to try to find which
are the motor machineries that are
causing this form of axonal transport
we decided to approach this problem by
just taking apart the system in a test
tube and see if we can put it together
again and find out what were the
critical components that were needed to
get membrane organelles to move in this
test tube environment so what we did
know were that microtubules were a key
roadway for this transport of membrane
organelles so we knew how to prepare
them from purify tubulin and we can make
very pure microtubule tracks the next
thing that we needed to get was the
cargo that was moving inside the axon
these are membrane organelles these we
had to get from the squid giant axon a
third critical component was the fuel
adenosine triphosphate that we knew was
essential and that we could fortunately
buy from a chemical company most people
including us thought that the motors
would be tightly bound to the cargo so
the experiment was to make all these
components put him back together in this
test-tube environment put it under a
microscope and see if we can see the
movement of these membrane organelles
occurring in this complete test tube in
vitro condition just as if it was
occurring inside of the squid giant axon
itself this experiment was originally
done in 1984 at an institute called the
Marine Biological Laboratory at Woods
Hole Massachusetts the day starts
actually with fishermen going to sea and
collecting squid and bring him back to
us
at that point we have the animals in
hand and we can begin our preparation
so for making the tubulin we had already
protocols that were developed for making
tubulin from bovine brain and we wanted
to adapt it to the closest thing that a
squid had to a brain which is something
called the optic lobe so our strategy
was to use the squid optic lobe as the
slow chemical source for squid tubulin
which we could then use to make
microtubules this part here is called
the squid optic lobe and I'm going to
start by removing this squid op optic
lobe right there which we'll use for our
biochemical preparation of tubulin from
the squid we wanted to then collect the
giant axon
the inside of the squid and now we're
gonna do the dissection of the squid
giant axon and this is the cartilaginous
backbone of the squid which is called
the pin and you can see it looks like an
old-fashioned writing pin and I can use
them also use this to point to different
parts so all of these lines that you see
here are axons they're all coming from
this body of neurons right here so all
of these are innervating the muscle and
the biggest of these axons is the squid
giant axon and it lies right along the
pen right in the middle here so this is
the axon that we're gonna have to
dissect out and there's one on either
side here so the next step is to dissect
out that axon we had to very carefully
get the giant axon tie it off remove it
from the squid and here we are removing
the giant axon
and a protective sheet that is covering
it there now we've got inside of here
our giant axon and we'll have to clean
it up later but that is the starting
prep before removing it from the squid
so this is the squid giant axon right
here what I'm doing is cleaning all of
that sheath and kind of material that is
covering the squid giant axon then we
needed to get the inside of the squid
axon out that can be done fairly easily
just by cutting it and then you can
squeeze out the inside of the giant axon
more or less like rolling out toothpaste
from a tube and that rolled out AXA
plasm which is the inside of the squid
axon was the starting point for our
preparation from there we had to then
prepare the cargoes the membrane
organelles and separate them from the
soluble protein fraction so inside a
cell many proteins are bound to
particular compartments of mitochondria
a nucleus a membrane organelle but there
are also many proteins that are freely
moving around in the cytoplasm they're
unattached to anything and these are
often called cytoplasmic proteins and
when you break open the cell they end up
being in what's called a soluble protein
fraction
so to do this we took the AXA plasm put
it in a buffer which is a biochemical
solution disrupt the axon with a pipette
Minh and then we place that disrupted
AXA plasm on something called a sucrose
gradient a sucrose gradient is a
biochemical technique that can be used
to separate or in other word is fraction
aid different components inside of a
cell imagine taking sucrose sugar which
may be in your kitchen and dissolving it
in water but now keep adding more and
more sucrose eventually it gets very
viscous and thick that was the general
solution that we used in this sucrose
gradient a very thick viscous solution
of sucrose in fact we made different
percentages of sucrose a very dense
layer at the bottom and progressively
lower density later layers higher up in
this tube we then put the axe' plasmic
fraction on top of the sucrose gradient
and then put it in a centrifuge which
would spin that tube around amazingly
fast
you
so here I'm going to put our sample in
the bucket here and it's very important
that you have a counterweight in fact
these two buckets have to be very
carefully weighed so the rotor doesn't
become imbalanced I'm going to put it
now inside the centrifuge
you
what happens then is all the material in
that in that sample start moving down
the tube through the sucrose gradient if
you're a very large object you travel
down that tube faster and that causes
the membrane organelles to form collect
there and form a little band between
that interface between the low and the
high density sucrose and this allows us
to get a very crisp band of those
membrane organelles that we could remove
with a pipette and then use in our
experiments but one thing you learn in
biochemistry is to keep all of your
fractions when you do an experiment
whether you think you may need them or
not in fact we kept other parts of that
sucrose gradient including one fraction
which is at the very top of the sucrose
gradient which was the soluble protein
fractions and again we just put that
aside and also placed it in the ice
bucket just in case we needed it later
now we had all the ingredients we had
purified microtubules made from purified
tubulin we had the membrane organelles
we had the chemical energy source ATP
and now we can add them in various
combinations and see what might work to
allow this magical process of organelle
transport to occur in the test tube we
found that when we added organelles
microtubules and ATP
surprisingly there was no movement but
we found that the organelles themselves
were not capable of moving until we
added this soluble protein fraction and
finally we saw tremendous movement of
these organelles along the microtubules
this was a really exciting moment I been
working essentially for 4 months to get
these organelles to undergo motility in
a test tube just like in the native axon
but the next experiment was even more
surprising it was called a control
experiment essentially wanted to make
sure that what we thought we saw moving
we're in fact the membrane organelles
and not something else that might have
been coming along with the soluble
protein fraction so the way to figure
that out was just to mix everything
again but leave out the membrane
organelles just add together the
microtubules the ATP and the soluble
protein fraction and we thought nothing
would happen that we wouldn't see
anything and then we can call it a night
and go home but what happened was really
mind-blowing we looked under the
microscope in the microtubules which are
these long biological polymers were
sliding around crawling around like
snakes on the glass surface that was
something that we certainly didn't
expect at all and in fact it even took
us a few minutes to even think about
what was happening here why were these
microtubules crawling along the glass
surface
after we overcome our amazement and
surprised by that result we then began
to piece together in our head what might
be happening
maybe that soluble protein fraction that
contains some agent that was causing the
organelles to move actually contained
the motor itself so the soluble protein
fraction had motors that were floating
around in it without the organelles and
these these motors would also be able to
stick onto the surface of this glass
slide grab hold of the microtubules and
transport these microtubules along the
glass think of a rock concert
the singer jumps off the stage into the
mosh pit and the people in the audience
who are stationary there grab hold of
the singer and transport the rock star
across we thought a very similar thing
was happening there with the
microtubules crawling on glass the next
day I was able to extend those results
to find that we could get plastic beads
in the presence of the soluble acts of
plasmic protein fraction also to move
along microtubules and this is sometimes
what happens in science you know you
work really hard you don't get any
results it gets frustrating you have to
persevere and then one magical day
everything really seems to come together
and the experiment is suddenly propelled
much farther than you could have ever
imagined and that's a little bit the
nature of science it's one persistence
counts for a lot
one has to be prepared for the
unexpected and one has to believe that
one's experiment is going to work in the
very end and I think once one has that
kind of experience one's also willing to
persevere on a lot of other accept
later in one scientific career as well
I I stayed on at Woods Hole over the
winter to purify the first motor of the
kinesin super family which was a new
motor protein at the time we now know
that kinesin is not one motor but it's a
large family of related motor proteins
for example in humans there 45 different
genes encoding different kinesin motor
proteins and there's so many because
they're involved in many different kinds
of motor activities not just axonal
transport which first motivated this
study but a variety of other cargo
transport and even activities in cell
division such as the construction of the
mitotic spindle and the separation of
chromosomes
these motility experiments really are
what opened up the field they first of
all opened up the field by allowing us
to be able to detect this activity of a
motor protein that was critical for the
subsequent purification in many ways the
purification is technical we had
biochemical techniques that were already
well-established that we could use to go
about and purify a protein so these in
vitro motility experiments really
provided the foundation of being able to
assay and detect the activity of a motor
protein that we could then apply to the
purification of a kinesin but it was
much more than that these in featural
motility experiments you know kind of
gave us this window into this life of
what a motor protein is actually doing
and how it might be working it it kind
of gave us an experimental tool that we
just didn't have before to study
motility
I mean before we could just look at
cells with a microscope a little bit
helplessly seeing all this motility
going on but not knowing really how to
dissect it or
to understand it or how to
experimentally manipulate it it was
fascinating of course but we really
couldn't get at the basic questions of
how these machines might actually work
these in vitro motility experiments
essentially opened up a whole new
frontier of how we can measure motor
proteins